and professor Rishel this is something
that you have written about a lot
particularly in the last five years
where is Germany right now in terms of
understanding its own history of debt
relief not very far I'm afraid to say it
is still news to most people in Germany
although I've been talking and writing
about these things for quite a number of
years now and I'm not the first one so
out in the industry among academics and
it is a known thing and this is not the
only debt relief Germany already Bennet
have benefited from debt relief and V
and the Great Depression in 1932 the end
of reparations which was the cost of
Germany's economic recovery in the 1930s
so it's not one debt relief it's at
least two if not more Germany is a just
viably proud of what it calls its
economic miracle of the last
half-century can we tie the debt relief
it received in 1953 from its creditors
to the economic miracle absolutely
probably not as a sufficient condition
but certainly as a necessary condition
we'll say there were other things that
were important too but it's very very
hard to imagine how Germany could have
dealt with the size of a debt burden and
it was very sizeable have made the
foreign exchange have could have
balanced its budgets could have had an
inflation free currency and still have
paid the state thank you very hard to
imagine it professor Paul to Guare a
year LS he talks a lot about everybody
facing reality and moving on to what has
been done in Latin America that takes a
change in attitude do you sense a German
generational change in attitude in
culture and in society that will get us
to some debt accommodation well I'm not
Paul de Graaf here's a colleague of mine
at the Elysee if there is probably some
generational change simply because the
younger generation is more pro-european
everybody is travelling around it has
become entirely common place to spend a
gap here abroad and all these things so
yes these things are probably the
a little bit going by generations and I
notice it very strongly when I talk to
older folks they still think very
strongly in terms of the nation-state
younger folks basically consider the the
different countries in Europe to be like
different states of the United States
it's a very drastic change mentality
professor we've got just a little bit of
time left but real quick when you look
at you know the language coming from
Berlin right now is no - what they call
a classical haircut how do you interpret
that would they extend the terms if not
a classic haircut I have to say they
have already applied the haircut in the
sense of extending the maturity and
everybody in Berlin is shouting that at
me that in present value of this is
already a 50% reduction mmm this says so
they are very impatient with the
situation but really what it's all about
is explaining that to their own public
is the difficulty walking out and and
explaining that to the terms